intense heat waves have been sweeping
across Bangladesh since April and
there's no sign of letting up there's a
limited rainfall even though it's the
monsoon season tea farmers in the
northeastern areas of Select region are
concerned they say their plants have
been affected by various diseases and
pests because of the intense heat and
low rainfall and the typical say they're
finding it difficult to work in this
heat
the tea leaves are not growing due to
lack of rain and the leaves are dying
due to heat from the Sun so we are
unable to meet a quota or get paid until
fresh leaves grow
according to the nation's Met Office the
heat wave is likely to continue for
another week
temperatures can vary from 36 to 40
degrees celsius
we have been observing for a while that
compared to previous years temperature
is gradually increasing mainly due to
global warming and also because there is
less forestation and greeneries and due
to this systematic rise in temperature
tea plants are getting badly affected
now
tea plants can Thrive idly under
condition of 30 to 32 degrees Celsius
high temperature not only lead to water
shortages but dry out the soil in Tea
Plantation but more seriously the new
leaves and buds are smaller and
unhealthy vulnerable to pests and
diseases in many plantations the T-Birds
have turned red because of the lack of
rain and intense heat experts say this
condition have disrupted the tea plants
photosynthesis process which has
resulted in stunted growth and a decline
in tea production
the Bangladesh tea board is advising all
Tea Garden some various coping
mechanisms to deal with the adverse
impacts of climate change like planting
more shade trees planting new varieties
of temperature resistant plants
improving drainage irrigation systems
and using various organic fertilizers
experts say if the severe weather
condition continues it could take a
significant toll on the local tea
industry free and disrupt the livelihood
of thousands of farmers Bangladesh